separation church and state is a is a
misnomer people misunderstand it of
course it comes from a phrase that was
in a letter that Jefferson wrote it's
not in the Constitution and what he was
explaining is they did not want the
government to encroach upon the church
not that they didn't want principles of
Faith to have influence on our public
life it was exactly the opposite
Washington said of all the dispositions
and habits which lead to political
Prosperity religion and morality are
indispensable supports and John Adams
came next and he said our constitution
is made only for a moral and religious
people that is wholly inadequate to the
government of any other and Johnson
there completely off the cuff just gives
a perfect summary of the role of
religion in public life and the way that
liberals have revised history to pretend
that we were founded as some sort of
atheist Nation or some other such
nonsense when our founding fathers were
extraordinarily clear about the not only
importance but the necessity of public
religion for our government to work just
rattles it right off knocks that
nonsense down